when you make a song muffin do you
decide I'm about to go create or you
literally like taking a poop showering
on a plane and you're like everybody's
Gary Vaynerchuk here at can 2018 at the
Vayner X lounge one of the things I'm
super excited about as you know is
talent in general and for me always
emerging talent is the most exciting you
know a lot of people at the office part
of our crew a lot of us are into music
and I've been really looking forward to
this when Big Ups to Huseyin and the
people with over at maverick that
partnership on the Vayner maverick side
created this incredible opportunity
we're in a in a few moments we're gonna
have labyrinth create you know his magic
to the audience here but before we did
that in my EverQuest to continue to
educate the masses on things that I find
interesting and create content I'm super
excited that you've joined me for a few
minutes to kind of shoot the [ __ ] chop
it up a little bit on everything yeah
for everybody who's watching who may not
know who you are
give me the origin story like if this
was the first comic book who are you you
know where are you from how'd we get
here what's your music about what are
you about
like I play multiple instruments I
produce my music I write my music I'm
basically a creator and and fully
sufficient yeah we write you produce
right we should sing perform and I kind
of came up and do you and you I
apologize we didn't notice I'd like to
cut off and get excited don't worry do
you do you view that as we're gonna be
seeing a lot more of that because you
how old are you definitely I'm 20 right
yeah no no way I didn't I didn't get the
other number and I got it it's ready
eight so but even at 28 you had the
luxury of growing up yeah in a
technology world where new technologies
at your fingertips for the 9 10 13 17 20
year-old version of you yeah do you
believe that that you know very artistic
people are gonna be able to be more
multi-dimensional if they're lucky
enough to have the talent because of the
technologies they have at their figure
in the platform was that a big deal for
you we've I think I just I was basically
on the cusp of this person with my first
record and I need a Gabe it basically
gives you the power to do whatever you
need especially to communicate whatever
you want to
and that's the mega mega important
because there's no middleman that's
right and it's usually end consumer like
a label with a certain my corporation in
the middle they have the chance to
curate that's right what you've got
that's right before it goes out and they
can be like you don't like that and we
don't want you to say that and it's like
so a true representation of your brand
so do you believe you know you're
preaching right now also help
it does it does help to have a label for
distribution
100% but do you believe that that means
that we're in the greatest era of
artists ever because in the beginning
yeah you're able to you know you think
about a lot of artists their first album
is always their best yes no different
than a writer's first book because it's
your life things that built up like when
you see a kid five years old innocent
pure without all of this [ __ ] that the
world put on them it's the most
beautiful version that's there the most
I mean you'll love this as a purist i i
genuinely believe the reason that I'm
successful
yeah is because i've under educated
myself on purpose so that i mean an
undereducated in the traditional sense
yeah yeah yeah it's like undo all the
other things i who would artists that
that you that brought you value and why
don't you first get into music and why
princes
then I very Prince Ray Charles all of
these guys are people that in a time
where they didn't have social media
found a way to create their own brand
and create their own voice and it took
them time but like Ray Charles was a
person and and I kind of look up to Ray
Charles and Prince is that they made
their home sound they made their own
thing and they were able to like respect
how much time it takes to share that
with the world to share your own
universe you caught that usually what
happens in the music industry or in most
industries is that you jump on the
bandwagon and the percent of the same
kind of long-term service someone's made
the platform for you there's only
there's only one or two pioneers that's
what we say you know it's a great make a
black point for yourself it's like
that's my thing that's what I want to do
is to make my own platform and do you
create my own sound so when I hear you
answer that is uh when people ask you
like inevitably as your growth like as
you're growing yeah which is you're in
the heat of that now yeah and you know
from our point of view why we want to do
here is like it's the beginning right
like it's about to get way more serious
real fast we can taste it in the
zeitgeist and the culture is it hard for
you to answer when people say who are
you like exactly that exactly that
because especially as if you see
yourself like something or you see
yourself as it's already then you that's
it I'm with you man I think you limit
your on its time in a long line of
[ __ ] Lorraine you're gonna it's
going to take you a long time to get to
where you want to be because you
free from that kind of you know like
from being like pigeon-holed into one
thing that's right and so my because I
learned to produce music because it
allowed me to go okay if I want to make
a jazz record I can make a jazz record
if I want to make a funk record or a
hip-hop record and I like basically
facilitating myself with all these
things allows me to be whatever you
actually I'm a very interesting question
yeah
are you subtly in a very weird way
potentially concerned of having a global
smash hit I'm a concern yeah it's an
interesting question right discuss some
easy ways to say no because I'm
listening to you do you know what if I'm
having a smashing and I've had hits
before bar oh you know what I'm gonna
the defining song and that's exactly
what the word is defining the finite now
go I know and that's what I say is that
once you become a king it's hard to
crush down your kingdom
it's basically yes pointy off your
throne and say okay can I tell you
something very interesting you don't
know a lot about me but this is almost
more for you seen indie rocker I often
think that I'm slowing the role of my
awareness yes because I don't want to
have to unwind the pigeon-holed nature
of a complete and utter one viral moment
yeah I'd rather put a deep body of work
and slowly ascend because it gives me
the freedom to do what I do yeah it's
like and that's kind of literally my
thing is that musical freedom music
stuff yes because endless of making
videos is tough but the way I make
videos almost doesn't allow it to ever
be a trillion views cuz there's so much
teeth behind it I really made people
yeah music stuff because you never you
know there's a there's a magic behind
music that out of nowhere it just
becomes you know the people take it over
very they people take it over oh it's
not a hundred thousand percent like to
maintain that as a creative to to go
against that one
people said we we follow this church or
we love this sound we follow you or your
movement because they see a sound yeah
100 percent to literally say forget that
now is very that's tough because because
consumers are cynical by Nature yes and
so if you change it yeah even if it's
because you and you're in the club
you're in the club and the guy is just
killing some hip-hop and then he goes oh
now I'm gonna play David Bowie John
emoni nonsan what the [ __ ] are you
talking about are you crazy
and a small percentage to get the
foolish because you're mixing it the
masses give you nervous love it
but the masses like where's that Biggie
[ __ ] oh yeah we'll do that especially
when you've got them going on something
well it's special when in the long run
when you see when you see the history
like Ray Charles when he went from
countries from soul or life he went from
rocky road to country would lose the
country people are like I'm crazy or you
would even did you watch look at his
what about what about what about when
Lil Wayne came out with a rock album
yeah that was hard even for me
can you embrace that follow that
mentality
me too do you think it was hard because
he's so smart that he did it he almost
forced it on himself versus at being his
natural way that can happen
that definitely can I worry about that
where you become a caricature of
yourself exactly yeah and you kind of
almost you wanna you wanna you wanna
when you when you blow up you want to
become a better version of what
and you kind of get one of yourself for
examples you know I'm sure what you've
been on yourself for but wanna get four
to myself since 1970 [ __ ] five man I
so get that you know because honestly
you know what just think about me and I
wonder if you would like cuz I've come
to learn recently more than ever that
I'm creative because I've always thought
of myself as a businessman but this is
this great you're preaching yeah I uh I
almost think the second I start
something is the apex that from that
moment on it declines yeah like from
idea to execution is the part it's a and
then getting everybody else on is it a
slow burn of me not loving it as much
anymore know what like it's kind of like
when when you leave things it's almost
like a flower yeah and when it's leaving
all the pollen and it's dropping seeds
and all of these things it doesn't think
about the seasons dropping it's like
when you respect nature and you respect
what you're putting out
you're not gonna analyze it too much
because you're respecting your creative
process if you gave me so love it for me
it's like it's kind of just drop the
seeds and walk away like stop trying to
analyze your preaching don't look of
course that's what don't look back yes
absolutely believe it's look it actually
has the hottest yet the respect what
you've learned yeah for pattern
recognition yeah but you can't dwell on
it yeah and that's why I say respect
nature because that's what nature I'm
the same way I call it respect the game
it's just the truth of that that's the
nature talk to me about the culture tell
me what's got your attention right now
what brands what artists what food what
clubs what alcohol what non alcohol what
sneaker what person
give me three to seven things Lambert's
[ __ ] with what are you co-signing
what do you yeah what do you have you
with right now you got fresh white on
white converse like what what are you
what are you about they're gone it's
converse your jam on sneakers I'm
already mix it up a lack of chrome versa
like I've been added as it delivered
some great I'm great like Snickers yeah
over the time and very comfortable yep
um but for me it's more about mentality
I'm not really caught up with a brand
I'm poor I would like like how free
cannot be whose mentality is a person do
you admire what I really respect when
Jay calls going especially with my
social media he's like [ __ ] social media
and I think for him it works it works
you know cuz it's his truth yes people
always say to me like this hey look I
don't use social media sorry I'm like I
don't even [ __ ] yeah I'm like I probably
wouldn't use social media if I was
normal about it I just think it's the
most important communication platform in
the world like I'm not I don't give a
[ __ ] I probably would have never drank
wine in my life if I didn't grow up in
it yeah I'm not emotional I want things
to be true to you and that's how I see
it as well
Kanye's were like oh we struggle with
we're kind of like some of the things
Kanye's up to what I'm saying I don't
agree with everything yeah yeah I like
the the freedom yeah like how how free
but do you think he's trying to force
like I almost I feel like it's not about
forcing to do I actually I'm taking it a
little bit different I'm wondering if
he's so smart that he understands
freedom is the ultimate yes that he's
trying to speed up the process to
freedom murder it's you know like it's
how I think about listen the only reason
I love being an entrepreneur yes I don't
have a [ __ ] about money yeah I don't
even [ __ ] about anything you know what I
like
yeah being my own boss I don't want
anybody to say anything to me ever about
anything ever
that's why that's probably why I
produced I like record and pretty much
do everything myself I just sit in a
room did you struggle with signing with
a label with the worry that some of the
creative director consumer [ __ ] like
what did you over communicate to the
label of like hey listen you got this
but once in a while I just need to throw
something on soundcloud that was a big
thing
to make money out of an idea well I
think create a brand acutely ebook I
personally feel that there's an element
of sharing that has to happen what about
physical places what places do you like
to visit like what's been a fresh place
like whether it's a lounge whether it's
a site fee in place whether it's a city
what do you [ __ ] with there physically
yeah I think what about vacation where
would you go to vacation
do you like beaches are you like to see
the pyramids or Skid Row I literally
when I'm in this when I'm creating yeah
I'm flying I'm on another planet so for
me I'm I don't do anything but create
like I don't need to go anywhere
yep I'm just like when I'm making a song
it's like I leave when you make a song
Munford do you decide I'm about to go
create or you literally like taking a
poop showering on a plane and you're
like [ __ ] and you go by literally on my
interests alive I just make music in
front of I'm just like this is what I do
like on the side this is your constant
flow just me it's kind of what it's kind
of how we think about it too like I'm
just in it I don't even live it I love
it yes that's a good way is that's
that's where is
no mana I [ __ ] with you oh yeah man good
luck to you yeah but I'm not God